[Musique]
du coup on aime ça
c'est ma première campagne
présidentielle une campagne très
importante au réchauffement climatique
le chômage toutes les questions de
société c'est pour moi d'une grande
importance que les jeunes puissent
engager il parle pas en bons sujets
politiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
[Musique]
vous tendez dans le carré jeunes
et un quart est jamais joué d'avancé au
fond de la salle
ça fait plaisir de voir les gens qui
viennent pour écouter hidalgo donc c'est
que les propositions sont bonnes les
sondages certes c'est les sondages mais
la réalité des urnes c'est pas la
réalité mais son âge merci de me faire
un triomphe à notre candidat a mis
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
geste envoyée
à
vous
[Applaudissements]
ça fait plaisir ne prend pas me mettre
la main à la pâte pour du coup les
élections présidentielles et voir
hidalgo à témoin
[Musique]
bon ça va ça vous a plu
multiprise ans est
pourtant j'ai 22 ans je
suis à la fac les études de droit
grâce à ses côtés en tant que
responsable d'un service je me vois un
peu en eur à l'école où j'ai commencé
mes études en fac où j'étais obligé de
bosser pour payer mes études du coup ça
me permet aussi de comprendre ni d'être
un peu mieux la vie qui est la sienne et
en quoi la politique tout simplement
pour essayer des jeux quoi
accessoirement égal elles pour ça qu il
langnau talent le désir
[Musique]
voire pire les femmes - et c'est son
principal revenu c'est vrai que bon
c'est pas évident avec eux avec la pac
et 193 l'appartement qui était dans 95
j'ai fait un peu le tour de l'île de
france j'irai mais il n'y a pas le choix
je suis obligé la
principale et seule fille de belmont
l'onu gpu mais tous les charges que j'ai
ils tiennent aussi un peu mes parents
parfois alors on sent quelques courses
j'ai tout simplement de me faire la
nécessaire même si ces étudiants et
voilà c'est tout c'est surtout pas
facile
[Musique]
et oui une a beau vous conscience des
problèmes que les jeunes rencontrés dans
leur parcours en tant qu'étudiant mais
l'a d'ailleurs fait des propositions par
rapport à ça pour pallier à ce manque
[Musique]
net de 5000 euros dès 18 ans ces cinq
mois vous permettent de jeunes voire
annoncé leurs études de pouvoir faire d
avoir des projets
[Musique]
au sein des jeunes socialistes c'est une
famille vraiment une famille unie c'est
la politique noble salut s'élèvent pour
laquelle on s'engage totalement de bonne
foi et ça c'est pas le pastis et c'est
un très très bon bilan et je vends ont
usé faire un
contrat cui
et un petit trac pour la campagne de
gbagbo à paris
madame après chaque chacun chacun son
avis madame vous avez droit d'avoir
votre avis et c'est passé tout mon âme
je ne pense pas que c'est hidalgo qui
vient déposer la crasse non mais jean
paul therrien pour fixer ce mois là
voilà quand même énormément agit pour la
vie il n'y a pas de trouver les bonnes
journées madame et bon week-end au
revoir là on a mis une dame qui m'ont
dit que les galgos a mis un peu de grâce
à paris elle a été élue les parisiens
ont décidé de les réunir je pense pas
que voilà les parisiens sont en soie
beth où nous sommes intelligents loin de
là il a été lui
la vérité des urnes ça c'est une
programme d'algos pour la présidentielle
je suis passé
invités
q
après en avoir eu toutes façons à 0 4%
sur laquelle on sait très bien que les
sondages oui mais voilà il a sorti son
programme je dis non dans le ça prenne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
même si d'algos ne parvient pas à
devenir un président et un public ce
combat je le mènerai avis ont le même
avis j'ai décidé de m'engager
personnellement pour le parti sioniste
et pour les valeurs du parti sioniste
avis je fus j'essayerai le plus de faire
émerger
ces valeurs là ces valeurs du de
social-démocrate ses valeurs a une
sensibilité sociale forte et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai rejoint parti
socialiste donc demain si la lgo ne
venait à pas remporter l'élection
présidentielle
c'est parce qu'il va faire que j'arrête
mon combat
merci merci j'espère en espérant que les
professions de mon père bonne journée